This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. For nearly five decades, the Laft Track was ubiquitous on television setcams, but in the early 2000s, it began to disappear. What happened? How did we get from the Rockas-Candle Laughter of the Beverly Hillbillies to these silent, sly, joke every 20 seconds of 30 Rock? The curious story of the Laft Track starts with one man who created the Laft-Track as a homemade piece of technology that took over the sound of television, and then fell out of fashion with the rise of a more modern sense of humor. What happened to the Laft-Track is just one of the cultural mysteries that are being explored
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。近五十年来，罐头笑声在电视情景喜剧中无处不在，但在21世纪初，它开始消失。发生了什么？我们是如何从《贝弗利山人》中那种摇滚乐般的笑声，演变成《我为喜剧狂》里那种每20秒一次的沉默、狡黠的笑声的？罐头笑声的奇妙故事始于一个人，他将罐头笑声作为一种自制技术创造出来，并接管了电视的声音，随后又随着现代幽默感的兴起而过时。罐头笑声的遭遇只是正在探索的文化谜团之一。
on Slate's new monthly podcast, Decoder Ring. Here presenting the first episode of Decoder Ring, called the Lafbox, is host Willa Pascon. When Paul Iverson was eight years old, he would come home from school, turn on the TV, and watch the Pink Panther show. It was 1982, and Paul was watching the show in syndication on WGN Chicago. Some channels aired versions of the laugh track and some aired versions without. I always watched the ones that had the laughter because it was, I guess, as a child it was
在Slate的新月度播客《解码环》中。现在由主持人威拉·帕斯康为您呈现《解码环》的第一集，名为“笑声盒”。保罗·艾弗森八岁时，放学回家打开电视，观看《粉红豹》节目。那是1982年，保罗在芝加哥WGN电视台观看该节目的联播。有些频道播出的版本带有罐头笑声，有些则没有。我总是看那些有笑声的版本，因为我想，作为一个孩子，这对我来说是一种……
communal to me. I said, oh, there's people watching with me and they sound like adults, they don't sound like children. He loved the show so much that he would tape it, but he didn't have a VCR. So he would use a tape recorder, one that only captured the sound, even though the Pink Panther show has very little dialogue. What even listening to, that's mostly what the Pink Panther sounds like. What I was doing was allowing myself to hear the laughs rather than watch the show visually
共鸣。我说，哦，有人在和我一起看，他们听起来像成年人，不像孩子。他非常喜欢这个节目，所以他会把它录下来，但他没有录像机。于是他用了一台录音机，只录下了声音，尽管《粉红豹》节目几乎没有对话。到底在听什么，这基本上就是《粉红豹》听起来的样子。我所做的是让自己去听笑声，而不是视觉上观看节目。
like watching a show with your eyes closed. And I basically started studying this. So who are these people laughing? Why are they laughing in the same order as they did last time? Paul's early encounters with the Pink Panther fostered a lifelong interest in laugh tracks. Paul lives in LA and works as an account manager at an insurance company, but he's a passionate laugh track hobbyist.
就像闭着眼睛看节目一样。我基本上开始研究这个。那么这些笑的人是谁？为什么他们笑的顺序和上次一样？保罗早期对《粉红豹》的接触培养了他对罐头笑声的终身兴趣。保罗住在洛杉矶，在一家保险公司担任客户经理，但他是一位热情的罐头笑声爱好者。
Paul taught himself everything about laugh tracks, how they're made, who made them, the difference between them, even how to make them for himself. The monkeys is a great show to think of because they killed the left track halfway through the second season. One of my goals in life is to re add the left track and not just let it but try to add it as it was during that season, using those same laughs. It's really a very
保罗自学了关于罐头笑声的一切，它们是如何制作的，谁制作的，它们之间的区别，甚至如何自己制作。 《顽童合唱团》是一个很好的例子，因为他们在第二季中途砍掉了罐头笑声。我的人生目标之一是重新加上罐头笑声，不仅是加上，还要尝试像那一季那样，使用同样的笑声。这真的是一个非常……
strange obsession because there's so few people you can tell it to but I love recreating them. I love isolating these clips and putting them on anything I possibly can. One of the shows that Paul tinkered around with is the ABC sitcom Modern Family. It doesn't have a laugh track so Paul gave it one. I just never had a teacher not like me before. Well I'm the stavis. Please she's a gym teacher. She's to teaching what Dr. Sus is to medicine. I don't think she didn't like you.
奇怪的痴迷，因为你几乎没法告诉别人，但我喜欢重现它们。我喜欢把这些片段分离出来，尽可能地放在任何东西上。保罗摆弄过的节目之一是ABC的情景喜剧《摩登家庭》。它没有罐头笑声，所以保罗给它加了一个。我以前从没遇到过老师不喜欢我。好吧，我是斯塔维斯。拜托，她是体育老师。她对教学就像苏斯博士对医学一样。我不觉得她不喜欢你。
Modern family premiered in 2009, but if it had arrived just five years earlier, it would have sounded something like that. From the 1950s to the early 2000s, sitcoms had Laftracks period. And then, when Laftrack free shows like arrested development and the American version of the office made its network TV, they mostly disappeared. Most sitcoms today don't have one, except for a few big hits, like the Big Bang Theory and reboots like Roseanne. When we talk about Laftracks now, it's mostly to make jokes about them. But when Paul was growing up and every show had a Laftrack, people didn't talk about them very much.
《摩登家庭》于2009年首播，但如果它早五年出现，听起来就会像那样。从20世纪50年代到21世纪初，情景喜剧都有罐头笑声。然后，当像《发展受阻》和美版《办公室》这样没有罐头笑声的节目出现在电视网时，它们基本消失了。今天大多数情景喜剧都没有罐头笑声，除了少数几部大热剧，比如《生活大爆炸》和像《罗斯安》这样的重启剧。当我们现在谈论罐头笑声时，大多是为了拿它们开玩笑。但当保罗长大时，每个节目都有罐头笑声，人们并不怎么谈论它们。
They were kind of a secret. So a few people knew about it or discussed it. Everybody hears that everybody is aware of it. Why won't anybody talk about it? Today, we're going to talk about it. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Growing up, I never thought much about the Laftrack one way or another. They were just always there.
它们就像一个秘密。所以很少有人知道或讨论它。每个人都听到了，每个人都知道它。为什么没人谈论它？今天，我们要谈谈它。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ 成长过程中，我从未多想过罐头笑声。它们一直都在那里。
But as a TV critic, I've watched Laftrack's become contentious and deeply uncool. It's always fascinated me that something we barely noticed for so long, something that we maybe even kind of liked, could become so annoying to so many people so quickly. What changed? Why did they exist in the first place? Did we just realize they were really lame? And if so, what took us so long? From Slate Magazine, this is Dakota Rin, a show about cracking cultural mysteries.
但作为一名电视评论家，我看着罐头笑声变得充满争议且极其不酷。一直让我着迷的是，某种我们长期以来几乎没注意到，甚至可能有点喜欢的东西，怎么会如此迅速地让这么多人感到厌烦。发生了什么变化？它们最初为什么存在？我们只是意识到它们真的很烂吗？如果是这样，为什么我们花了这么久才发现？来自《Slate》杂志，这是《解码环》，一个关于破解文化谜团的节目。
I'm Slate's TV critic, Willa Pascon, and every month I'll take a cultural object, idea, or habit, and try to figure out where it comes from, what it means, and why it matters. Today, what happened to the Laft Track? Imagine it's the 1950s, you've just gotten your very first television set. It weighs a ton and it's a size with a bureau, with wood paneling and a couple of dials on the side. You set it up in the living room and you call them the whole family and you turn it on. It's too late now, but ladies and gentlemen, I must tell you.
我是《Slate》的电视评论家威拉·帕斯康，每个月我都会选取一个文化客体、观念或习惯，试图弄清楚它来自哪里，意味着什么，以及为什么重要。今天，罐头笑声发生了什么？想象一下，那是20世纪50年代，你刚买了第一台电视机。它重得要命，大小像个五斗橱，有木镶板和侧面的几个旋钮。你把它放在客厅，叫上全家人，然后打开它。现在太晚了，但女士们先生们，我必须告诉你们。
It's the Jack Benny program. Originally a hit radio show, the series starred Benny, a one-time Vaudeville performer and comedian as a version of himself, a radio star. And now that show from the radio, it's on your television, and even though you've heard it before, you've never seen anything like it. Before, when you watched a performance, it was in public with an audience, and now it's happening in your house. Think about how strange, how new that must have been, and then listen. You hear it? Something recognizable, something reassuring,
这是《杰克·本尼节目》。该系列最初是一档热门广播节目，由曾经的杂耍表演者和喜剧演员本尼主演，饰演他自己的一个版本——一位广播明星。现在那个来自广播的节目出现在你的电视上了，即使你以前听过，你也从未见过这样的东西。以前，当你观看表演时，是在公共场合有观众，而现在它发生在你家里。想想那一定有多奇怪、多新奇，然后听听。你听到了吗？某种可识别的，某种令人安心的……
something that tells you what you're watching. Laughter. It was my sponsor who didn't have the nerve. Yeah. That's how most early TV comedies were recorded in front of a live audience, oftentimes in studios in New York. By the early 50s, as the TV industry moved away from New York and into Hollywood, executives wanted to move away from this traditional approach of broadcasting what
某种告诉你正在看什么的东西。笑声。是我的赞助商没有胆量。是的。这就是大多数早期电视喜剧在现场观众面前录制的方式，通常是在纽约的演播室里。到了50年代初，随着电视行业从纽约搬到好莱坞，高管们想要摆脱这种传统的广播方式……
amounted to live stage shows. They wanted to shoot comedies on film, comedies that weren't live, but they still sounded live. The solution to this problem? The laugh track, and the person who came up with the solution? Charles Douglas. Charlie. Douglas was a mechanical engineer who had worked on radar for the Navy in World War II, so he knew his way around audio and electronics. In 1950, the Hank and McEwan show, a mostly forgotten series from NBC, had used a rudimentary laugh track.
相当于现场舞台表演。他们想用胶片拍摄喜剧，不是现场直播的喜剧，但听起来仍然像现场直播。解决这个问题的办法是什么？罐头笑声，而想出这个办法的人是谁？查尔斯·道格拉斯。查理。道格拉斯是一位机械工程师，曾在二战期间为海军研究雷达，所以他精通音频和电子设备。1950年，《汉克和麦克尤恩秀》——一部NBC几乎被遗忘的系列剧——使用了原始的罐头笑声。
But by 1953, Douglas had developed a better way to insert a laugh into a show. If you've ever watched an old sitcom, you've almost certainly heard his work. Now we lift up the dryers and see how their hair turned out. I asked Ron Simon, curator of television and radio at the Paley Center, formerly the Museum of Television Radio, what he knew. Charlie Douglas took the concept of just adding laughter, probably from a transcription
但到了1953年，道格拉斯开发出了一种更好的将笑声插入节目的方法。如果你看过老情景喜剧，你几乎肯定听过他的作品。现在我们抬起烘干机，看看他们的头发变成了什么样。我问帕利中心（前身为电视广播博物馆）的电视和广播策展人罗恩·西蒙，他知道些什么。查理·道格拉斯采用了仅仅添加笑声的概念，可能来自转录……
disc, to create a machine that could do it. And he created this little box using laughter from Marcel Marceau and from Red Skeleton from the silent sequences and create a tape loop that could then be injected into film comedy to make it a live experience. Douglass then poured over these laughs at his kitchen table night after night. He spliced them into analog tape reels that could be played on a patented device Douglas had built himself out of household appliances, organ parts, and vacuum tubes. The device was about three feet tall, the shape of a filing cabinet, very heavy, and had slots for 32 reels which could hold 10 laughs each. It was officially named the audience response duplicator, but it became known as the laughbox, and that's laugh, spelled in the goofy 50 style, L-A-F-F.
唱片，来创造一台能做到这一点的机器。他用马塞尔·马索和雷德·斯克尔顿在默剧片段中的笑声制作了这个小盒子，并创建了一个磁带循环，然后可以将其注入到电影喜剧中，使其成为一种现场体验。道格拉斯随后夜复一夜地在餐桌上研究这些笑声。他将它们剪接到模拟磁带卷上，这些磁带可以在道格拉斯用家用电器、风琴零件和真空管自制的专利设备上播放。该设备高约三英尺，形状像个文件柜，非常重，有32个插槽，每个插槽可容纳10段笑声。它被正式命名为“观众反应复制器”，但被称为“笑声盒”（Laughbox），那个“Laff”是用50年代那种滑稽的拼法拼写的。
The laughbox is this weird machine that's closer to, we'll say, steepunk, that it is to modern electronic technology. As I can add a machine, we just press these dials and laughter would happen. Eventually, it would evolve into more of a typewriter thing where you would punch keys. The laughbox could chuckle.
笑声盒是一台奇怪的机器，比起现代电子技术，它更接近蒸汽朋克。作为一台机器，我们只需按下这些旋钮，笑声就会出现。最终，它演变成更像打字机的东西，你可以按键。笑声盒可以发出轻笑。
It could laugh with side relief. It even had a reel controlled by the foot pedal that was just hitters. Tiny little one person laughs. At its most sophisticated, the box had 320 laughs. It could play one laugh at a time by pressing one key, or by pressing multiple keys together, it could play a bunch of laughs at once. So if he thought something was remotely funny, let's have this guy laugh right here.
它可以发出如释重负的笑声。它甚至有一个由脚踏板控制的卷轴，专门播放轻笑声。微小的、单人的笑声。在最复杂的时候，这个盒子有320段笑声。它可以通过按下一个键播放一段笑声，或者通过同时按下多个键，一次播放一堆笑声。所以如果他认为某件事有点好笑，我们就让这家伙在这里笑一下。
And he just had that going. And maybe he'd come back and watch it. So you know, that wasn't quite as funny as the producer's going to want it. So maybe he would add a second sound like this. And then he would add it all together and mix it together so you hear the full product. Three separate clips overlapped. What would happen was the producer or the director would come back and see his work and say, you know what, that could use a much louder laugh.
他就让它一直响着。也许他会回来看看。所以你知道，那并不像制片人想要的那么好笑。所以也许他会添加第二个声音，像这样。然后他会把它们全部加在一起，混合在一起，这样你就能听到完整的产品。三个独立的片段重叠在一起。会发生的是，制片人或导演会回来查看他的作品，然后说，你知道吗，那需要更响亮的笑声。
Can you give it a louder go-fall? And he and say, you know what, that could use a much louder laugh. Can you give it a louder go-fall? And he'd say, all right, sure. So he'd throw something in just like that. Because laugh boxes were patented and handmade by Douglas, it wasn't like just anyone can make or use one. They're only a handful of working models at a time, and he basically had a monopoly on the process. By the 1960s, almost all sitcoms were single-camera shows, filmed with that in the audience, and tricked
你能给它一个更响亮的笑声吗？他说，好吧，当然。所以他会像那样扔进去一些东西。因为笑声盒是道格拉斯申请专利并手工制作的，所以并不是任何人都能制造或使用它。一次只有少数几台工作模型，他基本上垄断了这个过程。到了20世纪60年代，几乎所有的情景喜剧都是单机位节目，没有观众拍摄，并用……
out with a raucous Charlie Douglas laugh track. The boxes supply laughter for tens of thousands of episodes of television. Tens of thousands, maybe even more. Everything from the monsters bewitched the Beverly Hillbilly's Gilligan's Island to marry Tyler Moore and sheers. For decades, their sound was ubiquitous, but Douglass didn producers want to talk about and really actually talk about, you know, how the last sausage was actually made. Douglas hardly ever gave interviews or spoke about his work.
查理·道格拉斯那种喧闹的罐头笑声进行了修饰。这些盒子为成千上万集的电视节目提供了笑声。成千上万，甚至更多。从《怪物家族》、《神仙家庭》、《贝弗利山人》、《吉利根岛》到《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔秀》和《干杯酒吧》。几十年来，它们的声音无处不在，但道格拉斯并不想让制片人谈论，也不想真正谈论，你知道，最后那根香肠到底是怎么做出来的。道格拉斯几乎从不接受采访或谈论他的工作。
A 1966 piece from TV Guide titled The Hollywood Sphinx and His Laugh Box, in which the Sphinx is Douglas, describes the mystery surrounding the man and his device. The author wrote, If the laugh box should start acting strangely, the laugh boys wheel it into the men's room, locking the door behind them so no one can peek. I mentioned the name Charlie Douglas, and it's like Kosa Nostra. Everybody starts whispering.
1966年《电视指南》上的一篇文章，标题为《好莱坞斯芬克斯和他的笑声盒》，其中斯芬克斯就是道格拉斯，描述了围绕这个人和他的设备产生的谜团。作者写道，如果笑声盒开始表现异常，笑声男孩们会把它推到男厕所，锁上门，这样就没人能偷看了。我提到了查理·道格拉斯的名字，就像黑手党一样。每个人都开始窃窃私语。
It's the most taboo topic in TV. I wanna say here that every knock on the laugh track that you've ever heard, that it's fake, that it's corny, that it's cheating, that it's not funny, that it thinks audiences are dumb, people have been saying since the beginning, and that's part of the reason for Douglas's silence. But listening to Douglas's laughs, hearing Paul try to recreate them, it changed how I thought about them. I've always prided myself on being open-minded about the laugh track. A funny show was a funny show, with or without one.
这是电视界最禁忌的话题。我想在这里说，你听过的关于罐头笑声的每一个批评，说它是假的，说它是老套的，说它是作弊，说它不好笑，说它认为观众很蠢，人们从一开始就在说，这也是道格拉斯保持沉默的部分原因。但听着道格拉斯的笑声，听着保罗试图重现它们，这改变了我对它们的看法。我一直以对罐头笑声持开放态度而自豪。一部好笑的节目就是好笑的节目，无论有没有它。
But even so, I always thought of them as automated, mechanical. But they aren't really that at all. They're a craft. Charlie Douglas played his laugh box like it was an instrument, literally. A lot of people think it was just a bunch of laughs thrown into a tape machine and someone's pushing the button. It was an art. I mean, he took it very seriously. Here's one of Charlie's laughs. It was used in the late 60s and 70s, including in the pilot for Mash. You hear the laughter telling off at the end? I love that. It tells a story in a single laugh. There's a joke, but one guy in the audience, he doesn't get it right away.
但即便如此，我一直认为它们是自动的、机械的。但它们根本不是那样。它们是一种工艺。查理·道格拉斯演奏他的笑声盒就像演奏乐器一样，真的。很多人认为这只是一堆笑声扔进磁带机，有人在按按钮。这是一种艺术。我的意思是，他非常认真地对待它。这是查理的一段笑声。它在60年代末和70年代被使用，包括在《陆军野战医院》的试播集中。你听到最后笑声减弱了吗？我喜欢那个。它用一段笑声讲述了一个故事。有一个笑话，但观众席里的一个人，他没有马上听懂。
He's a split second late, and then he laughs a little bit longer. Here, listen to it again. Charlie Douglas was in just a sound engineer. He was a psychologist. The rap on the Laftrak is that it's fake laughter from a fake audience, but that's not quite right. The Laftrak doesn't just represent a bogus audience. It represents an audience of one of Charlie Douglas.
他慢了半拍，然后他笑的时间长了一点。来，再听一遍。查理·道格拉斯不仅仅是一位音响工程师。他是一位心理学家。对罐头笑声的抨击是，它是来自虚假观众的虚假笑声，但这并不完全正确。罐头笑声不仅仅代表一个虚假的观众。它代表了一个人的观众——查理·道格拉斯。
He definitely goose laughs at producers' instructions, but who a large extent he and the people who worked for him followed their guts. It's incredible that one man's taste and sense of humor were so important in pacing an entire type of television comedy. But it's true. So how did the Laft track drive an era of TV come to an end? How did the Laft Track go from being a tittering companion to an annoyance? To answer that, I think we need to think about the Laft Track as not just a habit or an
他确实会根据制片人的指示发出笑声，但在很大程度上，他和为他工作的人遵循的是他们的直觉。令人难以置信的是，一个人的品味和幽默感对于把握整个类型的电视喜剧竟然如此重要。但这是真的。那么，罐头笑声驱动的电视时代是如何结束的呢？罐头笑声是如何从一个轻笑的伴侣变成一种厌烦的？为了回答这个问题，我认为我们需要把罐头笑声看作不仅仅是一个习惯或一个……
object, but an idea, an idea about why we laugh. I'm going to get to another idea about Laft or later on, but this first one, I think it makes the Laft Track of the 50s and 60s make a lot more sense. Here, I want you to listen to something. Something that people once thought was really funny. That menacing sequence is from the OK Laughing Record. OK, OK-E-H is the name of the record label that released it in 1922. It was recorded a few years earlier in Germany, and it's the sound of a cornette being interrupted by a hysterically laughing woman who was joined by a hysterically laughing man. That's it.
客体，而是一个想法，一个关于我们为什么笑的想法。稍后我会谈到另一个关于笑声的想法，但第一个想法，我认为它让50和60年代的罐头笑声变得更有意义。在这里，我想让你听点东西。曾经被人们认为非常好笑的东西。那个威胁性的片段来自《OK笑声唱片》。OK-E-H是1922年发行它的唱片公司的名字。它几年前在德国录制，那是短号被一个歇斯底里大笑的女人打断的声音，随后一个歇斯底里大笑的男人也加入了。就是这样。
It goes on for two and a half minutes. Two and a half creepy, creepy minutes. But in 1922, people thought it was hilarious. The OK Laughing Record was a huge novelty hit. There's speculation it sold over a million copies. It spawned an entire many genre of novelty laughing records. The Laft Track, it's a version of the OK Laughing Record. It's trying to make you laugh just by listening to other people laugh. What's funny must be the laughter because it's not the joke.
它持续了两分半钟。两分半钟令人毛骨悚然的时光。但在1922年，人们认为它非常滑稽。《OK笑声唱片》是一个巨大的新奇热门作品。据推测，它卖出了超过一百万张。它催生了整个新奇笑声唱片的子类型。罐头笑声，它是《OK笑声唱片》的一个版本。它试图仅仅通过听别人笑来让你笑。好笑的必须是笑声，因为那不是笑话。
There is no joke. But this particular approach to humor, it's not that popular right now. To find someone to defend it, I had to talk to one of Paul's friends. Ben Glenn, he's an art historian by training, but he's also a devoted Laft Track enthusiast. He and Paul are in the same Charlie Douglas Facebook group. If you think about a show like that that relies heavily on the laugh track, like, be wist for the monsters. If you didn't have it, it just wouldn't be funny.
根本没有笑话。但这种特殊的幽默方式，现在并不那么流行。为了找到一个为它辩护的人，我不得不和保罗的一位朋友谈谈。本·格伦，他受过艺术史训练，但他也是一位忠实的罐头笑声爱好者。他和保罗在同一个查理·道格拉斯Facebook群组里。如果你想到像那样严重依赖罐头笑声的节目，比如《怪物家族》。如果你没有它，它就不会好笑。
Well, it might, but is that mean that shows just actually bad? And it was using like this crutch this... Well, yes, yes, partly, but, but somebody getting a pie in the face and then their silence is not funny, right? Somebody getting a pie in the face with a huge laugh, that's funny. I found this. That does a tree falling in the forest make a sound, Zen Cohen of sitcom laughter, genuinely perplexing. Is a pie in the face funny if no one laughs? Is an episode of Friends Funny If No One Laughs? That's what I wondered after coming across this video, posted on YouTube by the user Espoz, a friend without a laugh track. You can hear what the rhythm of the show is supposed to be, how the pacing depends upon
嗯，也许会，但这是否意味着节目本身就很糟糕？它是在用这种拐杖……嗯，是的，是的，部分是，但是，但是有人被派砸在脸上，然后一片寂静，这不好笑，对吧？有人被派砸在脸上，伴随着巨大的笑声，那才好笑。我发现了这个。森林里树倒下会发出声音吗，情景喜剧笑声的禅宗公案，确实令人困惑。如果没人笑，被派砸在脸上好笑吗？如果没人笑，《老友记》的一集好笑吗？这就是我在YouTube上看到用户Espoz发布的视频《没有罐头笑声的〈老友记〉》后想到的。你可以听到节目的节奏应该是怎样的，节奏如何取决于……
their being laughter. Without it, friends sound weird and unnatural. If there's no audience laughter, it suddenly star how odd it is that the characters aren't trying to make each other laugh. Friends needs its laughs to be funny, even if some of them are fake. The transition away from the Laptop started slowly. In the 70s, with Norman Lear sitcoms like All in the Family, comedy started to be taped in front of a live studio audience again.
有笑声存在。没有它，《老友记》听起来很奇怪且不自然。如果没有观众的笑声，突然发现角色们没有试图让对方发笑是多么奇怪。 《老友记》需要它的笑声才好笑，即使其中一些是假的。向没有罐头笑声的过渡开始得很慢。在70年代，随着诺曼·利尔的情景喜剧如《全家福》，喜剧再次开始在现场观众面前录制。
The audience's laughs would be smoothed out, edited, or boosted. This is a process called sweetening, which Douglas had done a lot of and still happens all the time. But the aim, already, was that the laughs should sound more realistic. In the 80s and 90s, some shows, like The Wonder Years, The Larry Sanders Show, and The Days and Nights of Mollie Dodd started to experiment with dropping the laugh track, but TV's biggest hits, shows like cheers, sign felt, and friends still had them. By the late 90s, with the rise of cable and un-laft-tracked animated series like The Simpsons,
观众的笑声会被平滑、剪辑或增强。这是一个被称为“加甜”的过程，道格拉斯做过很多，现在也一直在发生。但目标已经是让笑声听起来更真实。在80和90年代，一些节目，如《纯真年代》、《拉里·桑德斯秀》和《莫莉·多德的日日夜夜》开始尝试放弃罐头笑声，但电视上最大的热门节目，如《干杯酒吧》、《宋飞正传》和《老友记》仍然保留着它们。到了90年代末，随着有线电视的兴起和像《辛普森一家》这样没有罐头笑声的动画系列的出现……
even the network started contemplating making different kinds of comedies, setting up a collision between the old idea about comedy and the typical way of doing things and a new idea about comedy and a new way of shooting a TV show. Caught in that collision, Aaron Sorkin's Sports Night. You're watching Sports Night on CSC, so come on back. We're out, two and a half minutes back. In 1997, Sorkin sold Sports Night his first TV show to ABC. It was a comedy set behind the scenes of an ESPN style sports network. Sorkin and the director, Tommy Schlame, wanted to shoot it like a single camera show. The set had four walls, the camera moved, and they wanted to shoot it without a laugh track.
甚至电视网也开始考虑制作不同类型的喜剧，这引发了关于喜剧的旧观念和典型做法，与关于喜剧的新观念和拍摄电视节目的新方式之间的冲突。卷入这场冲突的是艾伦·索金的《体育之夜》。你正在CSC观看《体育之夜》，回来吧。我们出去了，两分半钟回来。1997年，索金把他的第一部电视节目《体育之夜》卖给了ABC。这是一部以ESPN风格体育网络幕后为背景的喜剧。索金和导演汤米·施拉梅想把它拍成单机位节目。场景有四面墙，摄像机在移动，他们想在没有罐头笑声的情况下拍摄。
ABC, not so much. They wanted to do something different, but not that different. Here's Schlamey. The economics of television and certainly half-hour television was so massive for shows that had had traditional life tracks that they were really very nervous about giving that up completely. What did you feel like the life track meant about your show? Here's what it is, the sort of base tone of a situational comedy is the laugh track. I think we're familiar with it. I think it sort of resonates in a
ABC，没那么想。他们想做点不同的，但没那么不同。这是施拉梅。电视的经济学，当然是半小时电视，对于那些有传统罐头笑声的节目来说是巨大的，所以他们对完全放弃这一点感到非常紧张。你觉得罐头笑声对你的节目意味着什么？这就是它，情景喜剧的基本基调就是罐头笑声。我想我们很熟悉它。我想它在某种程度上产生了共鸣……
certain way. But I think it is kind of establishing a conceptual idea about a show that is saying it's not real. This is a theatrical presentation. I'm there with this group of people. We're all laughing. It's fun. That was not the idea of the way I think Aaron wrote or what I think Sports Night was about. Here's a clip of the Laftrak from the Sports Night pilot. Yeah, but the point I'm making is that I can't, who is this? I'm Jeremy Goodwin. Oh, you're here for the associate producer job. Yes, and let me just say that it is important. It was one of the first shows, whereas a viewer, I could really feel that the Laftrack was holding the show back. Sports night is fast.
某种方式。但我认为它是在建立一个关于节目的概念性想法，即它不是真实的。这是一个戏剧性的呈现。我和这群人在一起。我们都在笑。这很有趣。那不是我认为索金写作的方式，也不是我认为《体育之夜》的主题。这是《体育之夜》试播集中罐头笑声的片段。是的，但我提出的观点是我不能，这是谁？我是杰里米·古德温。哦，你是来应聘助理制片人工作的。是的，让我说这很重要。这是最早的节目之一，作为一个观众，我真的能感觉到罐头笑声在拖累节目。《体育之夜》节奏很快。
It doesn't want to pause to wait for the audience's laughter. So the laughs have to be shoehorned into the rare breaks in Sorkin's dense dialogue, where they sound even faker than usual. Dispatches from a whole other sensibility. What you can hear starting to happen with sports night is a laugh track changing from background noise into an impediment. It's actively keeping Sports Night from being as funny and fast, from being as good as it could be. After its first few episodes, Sports Night stopped being taped in front of an audience at all, and the laughter got even fainter. Here's a clip from an
它不想停下来等待观众的笑声。所以笑声必须被强行塞进索金密集对话中罕见的停顿处，在那里它们听起来比平时更假。来自完全不同感官的快报。你可以听到《体育之夜》开始发生的事情是罐头笑声从背景噪音变成了障碍。它正在积极地阻止《体育之夜》变得像它本可以那样好笑和快速，变得像它本可以那样好。在最初几集之后，《体育之夜》完全停止在观众面前录制，笑声变得更加微弱。这是来自……
episode at the end of season one. Yes. Yes. You're breaking up now. Hello. You're breaking up. Now you're not there at all. There's nobody there at all. Yet I'm still talking. All right. For a second season, ABC let the show drop the Laftrak entirely, but it was canceled at the end of that season
第一季末的一集。是的。是的。你现在断断续续的。喂。你断断续续的。现在你根本不在那儿了。根本没人。但我还在说话。好吧。第二季，ABC让该节目完全放弃了罐头笑声，但它在那个赛季末被取消了……
anyway in 2000, just ever so slightly ahead of its time. The Laftrak-free British version of the office premiered in 2001. In 2003, arrested development started airing on Fox. In 2005, the American adaptation of the office started airing on NBC, the first huge hit without a Laft Track. That same year, everybody loves Raymond won the Emmy for Best Comedy. That's the last time a sitcom with a Laft Track has done so.
无论如何，在2000年，稍微领先于它的时代。没有罐头笑声的英版《办公室》于2001年首播。2003年，《发展受阻》开始在福克斯播出。2005年，美版《办公室》开始在NBC播出，这是第一部没有罐头笑声的巨大热门剧。同年，《人人都爱雷蒙德》获得了艾美奖最佳喜剧奖。那是最后一次有罐头笑声的情景喜剧获得该奖项。
The end of the La for Best Comedy. That's the last time a sitcom with a laugh track has done so. The end of the laugh track era. Oh! So what changed? I wanna talk about another theory about laughter. That's different from the pie in the face theory I mentioned earlier. In this theory, laughter isn't a fundamentally social activity. Something that we do just because everyone else is doing it. It's something deeply, wonderfully individual and idiosyncratic, a reaction to the quality of the joke itself.
罐头笑声时代的终结。哦！那么发生了什么变化？我想谈谈另一个关于笑声的理论。这与我之前提到的“派砸在脸上”理论不同。在这个理论中，笑声不是一种根本上的社会活动。不是我们仅仅因为别人都在做而做的事情。它是某种深刻的、美妙的个人化和特质化的东西，是对笑话本身质量的反应。
Representing this point of view is the TV writer Andy Sikunda. Andy's now a writer on the current ABC sitcom The Goldbergs, which doesn't have a laugh track, but his first show, the 2004 UPN sitcom Love Incorporated, about modern day matchmakers, did. But that's not fair, I have a dream too. What's your dream? To have $10,000 more. I'm talking about $10,000 to help improve the human condition. Well, $10,000 will help improve this human condition very much.
代表这种观点的是电视编剧安迪·西昆达。安迪现在是ABC情景喜剧《戈德堡一家》的编剧，该剧没有罐头笑声，但他参与的第一部节目，2004年UPN的情景喜剧《爱情公司》，关于现代媒人，却有。但这不公平，我也有梦想。你的梦想是什么？多赚一万美元。我说的是一万美元来帮助改善人类状况。嗯，一万美元将非常有助于改善这种人类状况。
Before working on Love Incorporated, Andy had been a writer for Conan and a teacher and performer at the Improv Comedy Power powerhouse upright citizens for Gade. I was an alternative comedy snob and coming out of the New York scene already was like every show with a laugh track other than Seinfeld is you know, Passe, a dinosaur. But Andy didn't have the clout to keep love incorporated from having a laugh track. The show was performed in front of a studio audience and they had some real laughs, but then a sound editor came in to sweeten it, boosting and manipulating all of them. So the real laughs were replaced by a laugh track. But
在为《爱情公司》工作之前，安迪曾是《柯南秀》的编剧，也是即兴喜剧大本营“正直公民旅”的老师和表演者。我是一个另类喜剧势利眼，从纽约场景出来已经觉得除了《宋飞正传》之外，每个有罐头笑声的节目都是过时的，是恐龙。但安迪没有影响力阻止《爱情公司》使用罐头笑声。该节目是在现场观众面前表演的，他们确实有一些真实的笑声，但随后一位音响编辑进来进行“加甜”，增强并操纵了所有这些笑声。所以真实的笑声被罐头笑声取代了。但……
Andy didn't want to use that laugh track in the typical way. So I guess my take was well since we're doing this anyway, why don't we just decide what's funny? To me I was like, if well it's going to be this creation, this false thing. Why go halfway? Just make the whole thing a fiction. I want to train the audience that's watching at home. It's not really paying that much attention anyway in my head. In other words, any wanted to rig the Laftrack to reflect what was really funny.
安迪不想以典型的方式使用那种罐头笑声。所以我想我的看法是，既然我们无论如何都要这样做，为什么我们不直接决定什么好笑呢？对我来说，我想，如果它要成为这种创造物，这种虚假的东西。为什么要半途而废？直接让整个事情成为虚构。我想训练在家观看的观众。反正我觉得他们也没怎么注意。换句话说，安迪想操纵罐头笑声来反映什么才是真正好笑的。
He understood how the Laftrack is supposed to work, that is supposed to make people laugh at what other people are laughing at. But he wanted to retrofit it to account for the second theory of laughter, to tell audiences hey, some jokes are just funnier than others and you should laugh at those. Andy didn't succeed, his boss wouldn't have it. But even so you can see, he may be skeptical of the laughter of the crowd, but he believes in the objective quality of the joke. You may be able to get a big laugh out of an audience and be not that great a comic. I mean a lot of comics would argue, well if you get to get the laugh, then you are a great
他理解罐头笑声应该如何工作，即它应该让人们在别人笑的时候跟着笑。但他想对其进行改造以适应第二个笑声理论，告诉观众：嘿，有些笑话就是比其他的更好笑，你应该笑那些。安迪没有成功，他的老板不答应。但即便如此，你可以看到，他可能对人群的笑声持怀疑态度，但他相信笑话的客观质量。你可能从观众那里得到大笑，却不是一个那么伟大的喜剧演员。我的意思是很多喜剧演员会争辩说，嗯，如果你能得到笑声，那你就是一个伟大的……
comic. It's great because I'm a snob. And he may be a snob, but his perspective has become widespread. This is how lots of people think about comedy now. Me included. Some jokes just are better than others, and you can't tell simply based on what got the biggest laugh, especially when that laugh comes from a laugh track. For decades, TV was ruled by this idea that laughter is socially contingent, and then that idea was surpassed by this other idea, that laughter is idiosyncratic and individual. But this was a big transition. For some viewers, the laugh track didn't just stop encouraging
喜剧演员。这很棒，因为我是个势利眼。他可能是一个势利眼，但他的观点已经变得广泛。这就是现在很多人对喜剧的看法。包括我在内。有些笑话就是比其他的更好，你不能仅仅根据什么得到了最大的笑声来判断，尤其是当那种笑声来自罐头笑声时。几十年来，电视一直被这种观念所统治，即笑声是社会偶然的，然后那个观念被另一个观念所超越，即笑声是特质化的和个人的。但这确实是一个巨大的转变。对于一些观众来说，罐头笑声不仅停止了鼓励……
laughter, it started inhibiting it. The laugh track broke. Today, shows with laugh tracks have been almost entirely cut out of the quadcopo conversation, but they still have their modern day defenders and uses, especially in the revivals of beloved shows that had laugh tracks, like Will & Grace. Netflix's 2017 reboot of Norman Lear's One Day at a Time, a show about a divorced Cuban-American veteran with PTSD, raising her son and teenage daughter while living with her mother is great. It's smart, it's charming, it's queer, and it has a laugh track too. She has to have a keen sis.
笑声，它开始抑制它。罐头笑声坏了。今天，有罐头笑声的节目几乎完全被排除在主流对话之外，但它们仍然有现代的支持者和用途，特别是在像《威尔和格蕾丝》这样深受喜爱的有罐头笑声的节目的复兴中。Netflix 2017年重启的诺曼·利尔的《活在当下》，一部关于一位患有创伤后应激障碍的古巴裔美国退伍军人，在与母亲同住时抚养儿子和十几岁女儿的节目，非常棒。它很聪明，很迷人，很酷儿，而且它也有罐头笑声。她必须有一个……
How else will we know the day that our little girl becomes a woman? You missed it. I was 12. I was in gym and ironically happened in first period. So just so you know, so this is this is a podcast we're doing about the Laft track. It's I'm wanting to talk to you guys because you do a great show that has Laft track. It doesn't have a Laft track. It's actually a live audience. I knew you're gonna say that, but we're gonna talk about all that in detail.
我们怎么知道我们的小女孩变成女人的那一天？你错过了。我12岁。我在体育课上，讽刺的是发生在第一节课。所以你知道，这是一个关于罐头笑声的播客。我想和你们谈谈，因为你们做了一个有罐头笑声的伟大节目。它没有罐头笑声。它实际上是现场观众。我知道你会这么说，但我们会详细讨论所有这些。
That's Gloria Calderon-Kellet and Mike Royce, the showrunners of one day at a time. They're right. Their show is filmed in front of a live audience, as was the original. Mike and Gloria say their sound editor cuts down on the a's and the more excessive whoops for Rita Marano and even trims down some laughs. But they say there's no sweetening in their show. When I said it was a laugh track, like, why does that bother you so much?
那是格洛丽亚·卡尔德隆·凯莱特和迈克·罗伊斯，《活在当下》的剧集主管。他们是对的。他们的节目是在现场观众面前拍摄的，原版也是如此。迈克和格洛丽亚说他们的音响编辑会减少丽塔·莫雷诺的笑声和更过分的欢呼声，甚至会修剪掉一些笑声。但他们说他们的节目中没有“加甜”。当我说它是罐头笑声时，为什么这让你如此困扰？
Some people just don't like to hear other people laughing because it feels like they're being told what to do. But part of that comes from, I think, feeling like the laughter is somehow fakedly added on. Mike is right. That is how some people feel about the laugh track. That it's a false advertisement trying to sell you a bad joke as though it's a good one. And sometimes that is what the laugh track is.
有些人就是不喜欢听到别人笑，因为感觉就像他们被告知该怎么做。但我认为部分原因来自于感觉笑声是某种虚假添加的。迈克是对的。这就是有些人对罐头笑声的感觉。这是一种虚假广告，试图把一个糟糕的笑话当作好笑话卖给你。有时罐头笑声确实就是那样。
So I asked why it was worth risking that kind of reaction. For me it's about a shared experience. So I feel like it's an opportunity to experience a play in the comfort of your home, but you're experiencing it as though you are a part of a community. We want them to experience the emotions, audibly. You know, like there is something about that, that crying too, by the way. For Gloria and Mike, the Laftrak is a reminder that other people are there, watching with you, even when you're all alone, just like it has been from the very beginning.
所以我问为什么值得冒那种反应的风险。对我来说，这是关于一种共享的体验。所以我感觉这是一个在舒适的家中体验戏剧的机会，但你体验它就像你是社区的一部分一样。我们希望他们能听到情感。你知道，顺便说一句，哭泣也是如此。对于格洛丽亚和迈克来说，罐头笑声提醒人们还有其他人，和你一起观看，即使你完全孤身一人，就像从一开始一样。
I want to go back to that scene from earlier, when you turned on the TV for the first time and saw the Jack Benny program, and it was so new and strange. When you heard the audience laughing, it was a cue that you should laugh to. Yes, but also it was a sign, a sign that you weren't watching alone. The laugh track was trying to bridge the bizarre new distance between the audience and the performers, between the audience and other members of the audience. The thing you have to remember, and this is so different than now, that the Laptrack was trying to overcome a defect of television, which is that unlike Vaudeville in the movies,
我想回到早些时候的那个场景，当你第一次打开电视看到《杰克·本尼节目》时，它是如此新奇和奇怪。当你听到观众在笑时，这是一个你应该跟着笑的暗示。是的，但它也是一个信号，一个你不是独自观看的信号。罐头笑声试图弥合观众和表演者之间、观众和其他观众成员之间奇怪的新距离。你必须记住的一点是，这与现在非常不同，罐头笑声试图克服电视的一个缺陷，那就是与杂耍和电影不同……
you watched it all by yourself. Now that defect, that you don't have to go anywhere, or interact with anyone while you watch it, that's one of TV's biggest selling points. And the Laptrack helped us to get to that point. For a long time, the Laftrak seemed permanent, but it was really more like training wheels, something that taught us this new skill of watching and laughing in solitude. It might have stuck around way too long, but it did its job really well. By the late 90s and early aughts, when the numbers of shows on cable started to skyrocket
你完全是独自观看的。现在那个缺陷，你不需要去任何地方，或者在观看时与任何人互动，那是电视最大的卖点之一。而罐头笑声帮助我们达到了那一点。很长一段时间里，罐头笑声似乎是永久的，但它实际上更像是辅助轮，教会了我们这种独自观看和发笑的新技能。它可能存在得太久了，但它确实很好地完成了它的工作。到了90年代末和21世纪初，当有线电视上的节目数量开始激增……
and the TV audience began to fragment, we were totally ready to move from one theory of laughter to another, to embrace the idea of ourselves as individuals with idiosyncratic comedic taste, who did not need or even want the laugh track's lame chortle of approval to know what was funny. These days, it's the laugh track that seems weird and vestigial, a sound from another time, and less were specifically after the theatrical, communal, throwback experience of a show like one day at a time. The laugh track has always been a tool, and nearly 70 years after it was invented, there's
电视观众开始碎片化时，我们完全准备好从一种笑声理论转向另一种，拥抱我们作为具有特质化喜剧品味的个人的想法，我们不需要甚至不想要罐头笑声那种蹩脚的赞许来知道什么好笑。这些天来，罐头笑声看起来很奇怪且残余，来自另一个时代的声音，除非我们专门追求像《活在当下》这样节目的戏剧性、社区性、复古体验。罐头笑声一直是一种工具，在它被发明近70年后，有……
nothing to fix. Watching TV alone isn't the weird activity, watching together is. As multi-camera comedies with laugh tracks have faded out, single-camera comedies without laughs have only gotten more and more adventurous, leading to a whole upheaval in what constitutes a comedy, full stop. Many of the busiest, most well-regarded comedies, like Atlanta and Girls and Transparent, are more funny adjacent than laugh out loud funny. They aren't after that big, big laugh. Making
没什么可修复的。独自看电视不是奇怪的活动，一起看才是。随着有罐头笑声的多机位喜剧逐渐淡出，没有笑声的单机位喜剧变得越来越冒险，导致了喜剧构成的全面剧变。许多最忙碌、最受推崇的喜剧，如《亚特兰大》、《都市女孩》和《透明家庭》，与其说是让人大笑，不如说是“好笑的邻居”。它们追求的不是那种大笑。让……
people laugh is really, really hard. One shortcut from decades ago was to fake that laughter. A more modern fix is not to worry about whether audiences are laughing at all. My littlest baggage would probably be my ABS. And my medium baggage would be that I truly don't love my grandmother. Like, you don't love her at all. Mm-hmm. Just know what your biggest baggage be. Got a my virgin? Obviously. Even if they're not laughing, audiences are finding
人们发笑真的非常非常难。几十年前的一个捷径是伪造那种笑声。一个更现代的解决方法是不去担心观众是否在笑。我最小的包袱可能是我的ABS。而我的中等包袱是我真的不爱我的祖母。就像，你根本不爱她。嗯。知道你最大的包袱是什么吗？我的处女？显然。即使他们不笑，观众也在寻找……
makeshift ways to watch communally. If you're looking for the present day technological equivalent of the laugh track, look at social media. Sitting on your couch, reading Twitter while you watch Atlanta or a football game or the Bachelor, those tweets are a signal about what's good and what's interesting. Sometimes, there's just a show's best jokes, tweeted verbatim. Often those tweets will make you laugh. They'll definitely keep you from feeling like you're watching all alone.
临时的方法来共同观看。如果你在寻找罐头笑声的现代技术等价物，看看社交媒体。坐在沙发上，在观看《亚特兰大》或足球比赛或《单身汉》时阅读Twitter，那些推文是关于什么好、什么有趣的一个信号。有时，只是节目最好的笑话被逐字逐句地发推。通常那些推文会让你发笑。它们绝对会让你感觉不像是在独自观看。
Learning the history of the Laftrac, thinking about it as a way to foster a feeling up to Gatherness, it really made me wonder. Is solo binging with headphones on, while the person in the very same room is you, watches something else, really better than gathering around one of three channels, politely putting up with canned laughter? And one of these experiences, you definitely get to decide what's funny for yourself, but you really are doing it all alone. I think this is part of what drives Laftrack aficionata as like Paul Iverson. When he tinkers with Laftracks and adds them back into old episodes of the Pink Panther or the
学习罐头笑声的历史，把它看作一种培养“在一起”感觉的方式，这真的让我好奇。戴着耳机独自狂欢，而同一个房间里的人在看别的东西，真的比围在三个频道之一，礼貌地忍受罐头笑声更好吗？在这些体验中，你绝对可以自己决定什么好笑，但你确实是独自一人在做。我认为这就是驱动像保罗·艾弗森这样的罐头笑声爱好者的部分原因。当他摆弄罐头笑声并把它们加回《粉红豹》或……的旧剧集中时
Monkeys, he's recapturing the spirit of a different time, a different way of watching television. When Laftr was an ajudgment, but a companion. When I asked Paul what his favorite Charlie Douglas laugh was, he had one of course. He got right to the heart of it. It was basically a deep man's laugh. That was used sparingly, and then it started to get used more regularly, and it sounds like this. When we heard that, my sister would say there's your friend. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ You've been listening to De Coderring, hosted by Willa Pasquim. De Coderring is a brand new podcast from Slate. It was produced and edited by Benjamin Frisch.
猴子，他正在重拾一个不同时代、不同观看电视方式的精神。当罐头笑声不再是评判标准，而是一种陪伴时。当我问保罗他最喜欢的查理·道格拉斯笑声是什么时，他当然有一个。他直接抓住了重点。那基本上是一个深沉男人的笑声。它被谨慎地使用，然后开始更频繁地使用，听起来是这样的。当我们听到那个时，我姐姐会说那是你的朋友。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ 您一直在收听由 Willa Pasquim 主持的 De Coderring。De Coderring 是 Slate 推出的全新播客。它由 Benjamin Frisch 制作和剪辑。
You can find out more about the show at Slate.com slash De Coderring. Or just go subscribe to it wherever you get your podcasts. It's good. You're gonna like it. One of the shows in radio- Topia is the West Wing Weekly, and the co-host of that show is Joshua Malina, who starred in the show Sports Night, one of my favorite television shows of all time, and is cited as the tipping point moment of the Laptop. So I asked him what it was like to act in TV show that was slowly turning down the Laptop over the course of the series. We have that conversation after this. Joshua Malina is the co-host of Radio Topia's The West Wing Weekly podcast with Recikase Herway.
您可以在 Slate.com/DeCoderring 上了解更多关于该节目的信息。或者直接在您获取播客的任何地方订阅它。它很棒。你会喜欢的。RadioTopia 的节目之一是《白宫风云周刊》(The West Wing Weekly)，该节目的联合主持人是 Joshua Malina，他曾主演过我最喜欢的电视节目之一《体育之夜》(Sports Night)，该节目被认为是罐头笑声的转折点。所以我问他，在一部随着剧集播出而逐渐减少罐头笑声的电视剧中表演是什么感觉。我们将在之后进行那段对话。Joshua Malina 是 RadioTopia 的《白宫风云周刊》播客与 Hrishikesh Hirway 的联合主持人。
Joshua is also an actor on the side. He recently wrapped up a seven-year run on scandal. He was also on the West Wing, but he got his big break in television as Jeremy Goodwin on another erensor creation, Sports Night. Sports Night was a strange and beautiful half-hour comedy with strong, dramatic elements, and the rapid fire dialogue that people would embrace more fully on the West Wing. But as was mentioned in the documentary you just heard, Sports Night marked the beginning of the end for the Laft track. I asked Joshua if he was aware of that dynamic at the time. It was always my understanding that Aaron objected strenuously to the inclusion of a Laft track on Sports Night,
Joshua 同时也是一名演员。他最近结束了在《丑闻》(Scandal) 中长达七年的演出。他也出演过《白宫风云》，但他在电视界的重大突破是在另一部 Aaron Sorkin 的作品《体育之夜》中饰演 Jeremy Goodwin。《体育之夜》是一部奇怪而美丽的半小时喜剧，具有强烈的戏剧元素，以及人们在《白宫风云》中会更充分接受的快节奏对话。但正如你刚才听到的纪录片中所提到的，《体育之夜》标志着罐头笑声终结的开始。我问 Joshua 当时是否意识到这种动态。我一直认为 Aaron 强烈反对在《体育之夜》中加入罐头笑声，
and for that matter, to the inclusion of a live audience in the studio as we filmed what was essentially a single camera comedy, so it was kind of being forced into a hybrid of which Aaron did not approve. And did you feel the tension of it being either a fish nor a foul when you were acting in it? Yes, I think as a performer and as somebody coming from a theater background and perhaps somebody who's a little bit of an innate ham. It is hard to ignore the presence of 90 people in a room where you're making a show, hopefully for millions of people to watch at home.
而且就此而言，反对在我们拍摄本质上是单机位喜剧时在演播室加入现场观众，所以这有点被迫成为一种 Aaron 不赞成的混合体。当你在表演时，你是否感觉到它既不是鱼也不是禽的那种紧张感？是的，我想作为一名表演者，作为一个有戏剧背景的人，也许是一个天生的爱演戏的人。很难忽视在制作节目时房间里有 90 个人的存在，希望有数百万人能在家里观看。
There is something different between a performance for camera and a live performance. And so while the priority ought to be the home viewing audience, I found it difficult not to play to the people who are in the room with me. Well, I'm very happy with my performance in the pilot. It's large. It's possible one can detect my playing to the live audience when perhaps I should have toned it down a little bit. But if you're asking me for genuinely sophisticated analyses and I sense that you are! You've got to give me some time of these 20 minutes.
摄像机前的表演和现场表演之间是有区别的。因此，虽然重点应该是家庭观众，但我发现很难不去迎合房间里的人。好吧，我对我在试播集中的表现非常满意。它很夸张。可能有人能察觉到我在迎合现场观众，而我本应该稍微收敛一点。但如果你要求我进行真正复杂的分析，而我感觉到你正是这样要求的！你得给我这 20 分钟的时间。
As the Laft Track itself was slowly muted, I think maybe my performance got a little bit smaller, a little more finely realized. So I think I need to back up a little bit to understand. So there is a live audience for the first season or what was the setup actually? There was a live audience for I think as long as there was a laugh track. And when Tommy Schlame and Aaron Sorkin finally outwitted ABC, simply by dialing it down a bit, episode by episode until it was gone.
随着罐头笑声本身被慢慢静音，我想也许我的表演变得稍微收敛了一些，更加细腻了。所以我认为我需要退后一点来理解。那么第一季有现场观众吗，或者实际的设置是什么？我想只要有罐头笑声，就有现场观众。当 Tommy Schlamme 和 Aaron Sorkin 最终智胜 ABC 时，只是通过一点一点地调低它，一集一集地，直到它消失。
So they never, they never won the explicit argument about a laugh track. ABC never said fine, get rid of the laugh track. They just got rid of it so slowly. You know, it's that thing, I guess, where you boil a frog. And it was, you know, de facto, they had gotten rid of the laugh track by the time ABC seemed to notice. So my memory is that that was somewhere around episode seven or eight. And having disposed of the laugh track, we disposed of the live audience.
所以他们从来没有在关于罐头笑声的明确争论中获胜。ABC 从未说过好吧，去掉罐头笑声。他们只是慢慢地去掉了它。你知道，我想这就是煮青蛙的那种事。而且，你知道，事实上，当 ABC 似乎注意到时，他们已经去掉了罐头笑声。所以我的记忆是那大约在第七或第八集左右。在处理掉罐头笑声后，我们也处理掉了现场观众。
It was already a weird situation to have the audience there when we were moving around trying to make our single camera comedy. And so there really was no existential point to the live audience once the Laft track was removed. It was one of those where instances where I think that a lot of us who grew up on television, the Laft Track was part of sitcoms and this was a very different sitcom. Did you feel the sense of
当我们四处走动试图制作我们的单机位喜剧时，有观众在场已经是一种奇怪的情况了。所以一旦罐头笑声被移除，现场观众就真的没有存在的意义了。这是那种我认为我们许多在电视环境下长大的人所经历的例子之一，罐头笑声是情景喜剧的一部分，而这是一种非常不同的情景喜剧。你是否感觉到
this tension as an audience member as well as a person crafting this thing? Yes, I'm not a big fan of Laft Track's altogether. Somehow in the golden age of TV, if the shows in black and white and feels like a theater piece anyway, like the honeymooners looks like they're putting on a play, it kind of works and has sort of an old school resonance for me. Certainly for what we were doing, which was creating a piece that included elements of comedy and drama, it just felt odd. It felt weird as we were making it. And when I watched it, that sweetened, super artificial laugh track, I think, does not elevate the show. And so over the course of the first season, while the Laftruck was being dialed down, surreptitiously, did you intuitively know to change your
作为观众以及制作这件事的人，这种紧张感？是的，我根本不是罐头笑声的忠实粉丝。不知何故，在电视黄金时代，如果节目是黑白的，感觉就像一部戏剧，比如《蜜月期》(The Honeymooners) 看起来就像他们在演戏，它有点奏效，对我来说有一种老派的共鸣。当然，对于我们正在做的事情，即创作一部包含喜剧和戏剧元素的作品，它感觉很奇怪。当我们制作它时，它感觉很怪。当我观看它时，那种加了糖的、超级人工的罐头笑声，我认为并没有提升节目的质量。所以，在第一季的过程中，当罐头笑声被秘密地调低时，你是否凭直觉知道要改变你的
performance slightly? Was that communicated to you in some way or not? I don't think it was made explicit. I think I just settled into the natural rhythm of acting for the camera. I think the best piece of advice I got as a young actor, learning how to act on film, was always remembered for the camera. I think the best piece of advice I got as a young actor, learning how to act on film, was always remembered that the camera can read your mind. And that's a very different piece of advice from, you know, make sure your performance reaches
表演稍微一点？这是以某种方式传达给你的吗？我不认为它是明确表达出来的。我想我只是适应了为摄像机表演的自然节奏。我认为我作为一名年轻演员，学习如何拍电影时得到的最好建议是，永远记住摄像机。我认为我作为一名年轻演员，学习如何拍电影时得到的最好建议是，永远记住摄像机可以读懂你的心思。这与你知道的确保你的表演达到
the person in the last row of the balcony. And so there are baked in inherent differences between a live performance and a performance for camera. So once the audience was actually gone, I think I just settled into, okay, we're making a TV show. And you know, that camera is going to get in really close when it needs to. And I can just sort of let go of the idea of trying to project anything. I could just sort of let go of the idea of trying to project anything. So what do you think of sports night being this pivotal moment in Laft Track history? The situation with the Laft Track and ABC versus Aaron and Tommy reflected a very significant misunderstanding on the network's part of what the show was and
阳台最后一排的人的建议是非常不同的。因此，现场表演和摄像机表演之间存在着固有的差异。所以一旦观众真的离开了，我想我只是适应了，好吧，我们正在制作一个电视节目。而且你知道，当需要的时候，摄像机会靠得很近。我可以放下试图投射任何东西的想法。我可以放下试图投射任何东西的想法。那么你认为《体育之夜》是罐头笑声历史上的关键时刻，你怎么看？罐头笑声以及 ABC 与 Aaron 和 Tommy 之间的局势反映了电视网对该节目的本质存在非常重大的误解，并且
So I think it's just one off-shoot of they're not quite knowing what they had or what to do with sports night And I think we're very used to seeing single camera comedies and we're used to seeing Television shows that one might have difficulty classifying as a comedy or a drama. I don't know why this was such a, you know, why things are so binary, you know, 20 years ago. Now we're a little bit more sophisticated as an audience and we understand that much like life TV shows can have moments of drama and moments of comedy. But I think at the time, ABC didn't quite know how to handle what Aaron and Tommy were giving them. Right.
所以我认为这只是他们不太了解自己拥有什么或如何处理《体育之夜》的一个分支。我认为我们非常习惯看到单机位喜剧，我们也习惯看到可能难以归类为喜剧或戏剧的电视节目。我不知道为什么 20 年前事情会如此二元化。现在作为观众，我们稍微成熟了一些，我们明白就像生活一样，电视节目可以有戏剧时刻，也可以有喜剧时刻。但我认为当时，ABC 不太知道如何处理 Aaron 和 Tommy 给他们的东西。对。
The, the, the, the, the left track was reflection of that tension. Like a lot of things, the, the first guy through the wall gets the bloodiest. Right. And then we've all benefited from that fight because of West Wing and 30 Rock and all these things that I think you could point to this moment and go, the Piric Victory of Sports Night made it so that all this other great TV happened as well. You have to understand, I think of Sports Night as this complete success. Like I love it so much. I appreciate that.
罐头笑声是那种紧张感的反映。像许多事情一样，第一个穿过墙的人流血最多。对。然后我们都从那场战斗中受益，因为《白宫风云》和《我为喜剧狂》(30 Rock) 以及所有这些我认为你可以指出这一时刻并说，《体育之夜》的惨胜使得所有这些其他伟大的电视节目也得以发生。你必须明白，我认为《体育之夜》是一个完全的成功。我非常喜欢它。我很感激这一点。
So this strange little object, it fought a battle that really changed a lot of television that we admire today. I agree with you. It feels like a platitude to say that anything was before its time, or that's why we didn't do better because we were before our time. But I think it's actually an apt phrase here, and I do think Aaron Sorkin and Tommy Schlame in terms of the material that Aaron was writing and the way that Tommy was filming it, that I think they were truly a little bit ahead of the curve, and it did ultimately take a little more time
所以这个奇怪的小东西，它打了一场确实改变了我们今天钦佩的许多电视节目的战斗。我同意你的看法。说任何事情超前于时代，或者这就是我们没有做得更好的原因，因为我们超前于时代，这听起来像是一句陈词滥调。但我认为这在这里是一个恰当的短语，我确实认为 Aaron Sorkin 和 Tommy Schlamme 在 Aaron 编写的材料和 Tommy 拍摄它的方式方面，我认为他们确实稍微领先于潮流，而且它最终确实需要多一点时间
for audiences to come around for this type of material. But I agree with you. Look, we did 45 episodes, we got a couple seasons, and I feel happy, and that I was part of it and proud of what we ultimately put out. Joshua Molina is the co-host of the West Wing Weekly, an addictive and rigorous discussion of the TV show The West Wing. Trust me, it's great, and the they've formed around the podcast is just like this warm embrace.
让观众接受这种类型的材料。但我同意你的看法。看，我们拍了 45 集，我们拍了几季，我感到很高兴，我参与其中，并为我们最终呈现的作品感到自豪。Joshua Malina 是《白宫风云周刊》的联合主持人，这是一场对电视剧《白宫风云》令人上瘾且严谨的讨论。相信我，它很棒，他们围绕播客形成的社区就像一个温暖的拥抱。
So proud to have them part of the radio-topia crew. 99% of visible is Avery Truffman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Shereefuse of Terran Mazza, composer Sean Riel, digital director Kirk Colessted senior editor, Delaney Hall, senior producer, Katie Mingle, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Roe. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a part of radio-topia from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative, nicest, smelling shows and all of podcasting.
非常自豪能让他们成为 RadioTopia 团队的一员。《99% 无形》(99% Invisible) 的成员有 Avery Truffman、Emmett Fitzgerald、Sherif Youssef、Taran Mazza，作曲家 Sean Real，数字总监 Kirk Colstedt，高级编辑 Delaney Hall，高级制作人 Katie Mingle，以及我，Roman Mars。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的 Radio Row 制作。我们是 PRX 旗下 RadioTopia 的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最优秀、最具创新性、气味最芬芳的节目的集合。
We are supported by our listeners, just like you. You can find 99% of visible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But I bet even the most dedicated of you hasn't heard every episode of 99% visible, and you can remedy that. By downloading them all right now
我们得到像你一样的听众的支持。你可以在 Facebook 上找到《99% 无形》并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上 @Roman Mars 或 @99pi.org 关注该节目。我们在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上也有账号。但我敢打赌，即使是最忠实的听众也没有听过《99% 无形》的每一集，你可以补救这一点。通过现在下载它们全部
on your favorite podcasting app, I recommend Radio Public, but they also live beside words and videos and pictures and a bunch of other design stories at 99PI.work. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在你最喜欢的播客应用程序上，我推荐 RadioPublic，但它们也与文字、视频、图片和许多其他设计故事一起存在于 99pi.org 上。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。